the English thinker and writer GK
Chesterton wrote of parents and
education that if you exalt education
you have to exalt the parental power
with it parents may not have all the
content background for all subjects all
grade levels but one thing that every
parent can do regardless of the subject
regardless of the grade level is to help
instill the right habits for economic
success and their students while they're
at home here are a few ideas on how that
can be done so that the practices the
parents instill in their students at
home can be reflected in academic
success at school one of the most
important things that parents can do is
talk about their motivations for doing
well
parents can talk with their students to
move them to the place where we want all
of our students to be that is to love
learning for itself to really enjoy it
and it's the love of learning that we
really want to cultivate in our students
talking with them about this motivation
frequently at home can be one of the
best ways to set students up for
academic success as everything is
oriented towards a higher purpose than
merely do accomplishing the next thing
in the list it's also important to help
students become organized usually when
we talk about is a ssin the first
impulse of parents is to go out and buy
a bunch of things that could be helpful
but try to keep it simple right the idea
here is that we have systems in place
that students can follow and practice to
help them stay organized and the younger
grades and through middle school
especially as the students are beginning
to take more ownership of their own
organization having predictable systems
in place especially for things such as
noting homework and which homework has
to be done and when it's due and keeping
track of papers in particular and other
things that come home and have to be
returned to school or have the utmost
important importance so the overall role
is to keep it simple and predictable
okay but parents need to help students
stay organized it doesn't come naturally
it's something we have to learn parents
have to be involved in that it helps
doings gradually to take ownership of
themselves academic discipline can be
very challenging for students and this
often results in poor grades simply
because the student isn't studying or is
forgetting to turn in their homework or
not doing their homework
it's unfortunate that they have reflux
in poor grades because that's not
actually grades are supposed to reflect
the students actual knowledge of
something or their ability to do a
certain skill it's not supposed to
reflect how well discipline they
about accomplishing their homework or
keeping track of things discipline is
about forming habits these bad habits of
not turning in your homework or getting
things done and in the right time or
with the right quality those are meant
to be corrected with discipline so one
of the things that parents can do a
really great job at at home is to make
sure that there's students that there
are consequences for not doing homework
it's not merely reflected in the grade
in school in school ideally that will
mean that every grade that the student
has earned in the class in the class
will actually be reflective of knowledge
they know or skills they have and not
whether or not they turned in their
homework assignment we oftentimes think
of paying attention is this very passive
thing that if we're just a body in the
room and we're listening then we're
going to actually be hearing everything
that's happening and understanding this
just not the case one of the things
parents can do to help students in this
regard with paying attention which can
be particularly difficult in certain
grade levels and with certain students
is to have a conversation with theirs
with their child about what it means to
pay attention and paying attention is
active as such I encourage your students
to ask questions in class that's one of
the best ways to be engaged is for the
student to be looking to ask questions
of their teacher from about third grade
on up notes are part of the education
particularly in classes such as history
and science but they go for almost any
subject across the board one of the
things that parents can play especially
important role in with respect to
note-taking is just making sure students
are taking their notes and then it's
clear any good teacher should do this
from time to time but teachers have a
lot of students parents every night a
great practice can be for you to talk
with your child and ask them to show you
the notes that they took that day from
the various classes by going through
with students on a nightly basis what
notes they've taken during that day in
class and asking them to explain some of
those things can be a great way to
reinforce that notes are important and
helpful and that there's some
accountability at home to make sure that
students are actually taking them while
at school
the typical way that parents are
involved with their students education
is usually through their homework
assignments and being aware that they
have homework to do I have a few ideas
about how we can structure homework time
in a predictable manner
that will help students do really well
and first have a set time and place that
students do homework
night maybe it's after they've had a
little bit of a break but before dinner
or maybe it's after dinner for sir my
own time but make it consistent once it
becomes a habit and becomes part of the
daily schedule students don't push
against it they're comfortable with it
and it sets a nice rhythm for the home
also make sure that it's the it's the
same place every time okay make sure
it's a quiet place where they can focus
understand this can be difficult in some
families where there's a lot going on
especially in the lower school and
middle school years make it a place
where it's observable where the where
you as a parent can actually see them
doing their homework this doesn't you
have to be checking in all the time just
to see that they're on task
connected with this is making sure that
there's no other distractions such as TV
or the internet or phones having any of
those present immediately cuts down in
the pit the student's ability to pay
attention to what they're trying to
achieve um also make sure you build in
breaks to the homework it's not good to
just slog through for some other school
students 30 every 30 minutes they should
get some sort of break even if it's just
a walk around to take a take a breath of
fresh air I would discourage that you
use that break to check the internet or
go on your phone or something it's
really hard to switch to that and get
back into study mode perhaps one of the
most important parts of parent
involvement and students homework is
taking an interest in it every day it's
good for parents to ask of each of their
children what homework do you have
tonight what subjects what classes what
type of assignment is it and then ask
them how they feel about the homework
assignment sometimes students are very
overwhelmed and they just need to talk
through it with their parent it's a
great way to have a conversation with
them and to support them in that and be
a Curt encouraging to them right so ask
them about how they're feeling about
that homework assignment and if there's
anything that you can help them with not
they're going to step in and do it for
them but maybe they just think I work
through something and they need somebody
to talk to talk with about it and that's
a great way to to support them in their
homework and also to build a
relationship between you and them that's
surrounded or centered on that education
when it comes to studying and
assessments this is an area where
parents are frequently at a loss of how
to how to best assist and usually it
comes down to I'm going to take the
study guide and help them work through
it and that may be a great way to to
work with students but there are some
other things to keep in mind as well for
one
don't wait until there's a test on the
calendar or assigned to your student to
begin reviewing with them punctuating
the weeks leading up to a test with a
frequent review of the material is a
great way to instill it so that when the
test comes about there's not it's not a
sudden I've haven't looked at this for
several weeks kind of reaction from the
student okay so continuing talking about
homework in school is a great way to
prepare students for a test even before
the test is assigned another thing to
talk about with students is to give them
a matter of perspective when it comes to
tests in some ways tests should be one
of the one of the easier parts of the
students education because they've
already seen all the material before you
know this is this is really review for
them and helping them to understand that
it can be a great way to dispel some of
the fears and anxieties that come with
that come with testing as well one of
the great things about studying time too
is that this is the chance for the
student really to to know the the
content or to master the skill it is
about mastery this is where it's
reinforced and the student it has the
greatest chance of its thing with the
student if this is done in the right way
all the things that I mentioned about
homework also applied to studying quiet
space set time may be the one thing I
would add to that is being able to space
out the the studying spread it over
several days and not just the night
before that will help the student to
feel more comfortable and though there's
a greater chance that they will actually
have had the right amount of time and
ability to revisit material in order to
do well on the test put tests on your
calendar be aware of them this goes for
long term assignments too and check in
with students to make sure that they're
that they are doing that along the way
and then lastly be encouraging support
your child tell them you can do this
right this is this is not something
that's supposed to trip you up or be
tricky okay
assist them and give them that support
and back a backdrop that is going to
give them confidence when they're
heading in to take the test
there are increase in number of studies
that are showing the very detrimental
effects that these have on a student's
ability to pay attention to things to
comprehend and so just be very wary of
those things sometimes I've had students
where they're really struggling with
paying attention or
making school and after talking with
their parents we realized that they're
spending a lot of time playing video
games or on the phone and usually
parents come to some understanding that
they need to cut that back a little bit
and when they do so it's it's show it
really shows in the classroom and then
sometimes they'll be a little bit of
slip-up in that and we look back and we
follow up with parents and they say oh
yeah well they were doing very well in
school and so we got gig go let them
have some of that time back well it
reflected itself in the classroom and in
their study so just be very very aware
of the fact that that the screen time
really can can have on a student's
ability interest in school and ability
to pay attention in class and doing
homework the most important role of the
parents in the child's education and
especially instilling discipline is to
be engaged to have conversations with
their student school shouldn't just
remain at school they the parents should
ask students about school frequently
they should ask good questions they sure
to ask questions of what did you learn
today in each subject and and what did
you like about that what did you find
interesting okay and ask the best
question to ask is just why have them
re-- explain how have them retell a
story from history or how that haven't
explained how a procedure works in
science or even in the math class right
engaging students in this way by asking
questions turning into a conversation is
a great way to help students be direct
students and all their habits towards
being successful in school we're not
going for for perfection
with their students that the grades are
not the reason why we're doing this and
the reason we're doing this is for a
love of learning as such celebrate glow
improvement and celebrate optics in
their morale towards school celebrate
any incremental step that they're kind
of that they're looking to get become
better at it's not about being perfect
in all these things but it's really
about making sure that they have a
healthy attitude towards school towards
their studies and they love it
above all I would just suggest the
parents that they try to learn through
their students let this education filter
into the home
ask your child questions about their
education and when you ask those
questions
ask them because you actually want to
know you genuinely want to learn from
them and let them be the teacher right
that's one of the best ways to to to
cultivate good habits in your child
instead want allow them to teach is to
have them have an interest in school by
sharing it with their home and have
those conversations come alive at home
we want you to love learning too so keep
asking questions
keeping involved seek to learn from your
child seek to show that you love
learning and these are the some of the
best ways that but will lead to academic
success for your child and a very happy
and healthy academic career for them